hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow season finale video if you
didn't know they're changing the format
of the show going into season four so
I'll explain how that's gonna work that
that's basically what all that stuff at
the end of the episode was about marc
guggenheim also revealed that there was
a death in this episode that would stick
for good like he said it would stick
meaning that they're not gonna bring him
back to life so I'll explain that too
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet what I'm gonna do
is my top seven moments just to give a
little extra room because there's a
whole bunch of stuff in this episode
starting with number seven Oliver in
Nyssa crashed the plane couples that
crash planes together stayed together
although to be fair Nyssa went back to
the League of Assassins at the end of
the episode
Felicity made that joke about Oliver
getting his marriage and old I kind of
liked that they let that hang in the air
like technically he is still married
then working together in this episode
especially like the first half of the
episode was a lot of fun no matter what
kind of long con Oliver was pulling
Nyssa was still unhappy to be married to
him so even though she seemed really
protective of him whenever they first
dropped into the arrow cave or the atom
cave I guess we should call it that
doesn't mean that there's anything
between them Nyssa is just like hard
core on tasks like we need to get rid of
this virus and get rid of Rachele goal
get rid of my father the follow-up to
that was when she smiled at Oliver when
she said I wanted to be the one to kill
my father
of all the newer female characters on
the show she's been my favorite they
haven't made any announcements about
Nyssa in season four but she'll
definitely come back any time they do a
league of assassins story now they can
do Merlyn they can do Nyssa stuff on to
number six Barry Allen helps team arrow
escape so here's the second part of the
arrow flash finale crossover in case you
didn't see me explain it the timeline is
flash episode 22 arrow episode 22 arrow
episode 23 the Oliver's wedding to Nyssa
took place after he left firestorm in
the flash in episode 22 the CW network
just got a little wonky with the air
dates one of the fun things about
bringing the flash on arrow is is they
get to have a little bit more fun they
get to tell more jokes the hot tub joke
that was the best thing ever the writers
said that behind the scenes they call
that their hot tub set the Lazarus Pit
set just because it does look like a hot
tub hot tub Lazarus machine for those
asking about time travel you know a
bunch of stuff happened in the arrow
finale none of that is going to be
negated by time travel that happens on
the flash they'll explain why that is on
the
finale onto number five flashback Oliver
gets justice this was such a fun vicious
Oliver moment Oliver before he vowed to
stop killing people even katanas like
wow dude that's messed up then he
proceeds to get on that boat
that's mysteriously marked Coast City as
you well know that is Hal Jordan City
the Green Lantern's hometown they keep
dropping Ferris air Easter eggs I feel
like at some point they're just gonna
have to step it up a little bit so it
seems like the flashbacks next season
will be to Coast City that's not
confirmed or anything that's just a
theory this could be a misdirect but I
don't think that they would show that
Coast City Easter Egg if they weren't
intending on paying it off onca number
four Merlyn calls the shots
he's been so much more fun this year
even as nice as he's been he's still
Merlyn at his core he believes that what
he's doing is right even if it's
completely twisted he's a little bit of
a psychopath which is why he's so much
fun to watch I mean John Barrowman is a
great actor too but first he had that
moment where he was like I believe the
words you are looking for are thank and
you then cut to the Adam cave and he
just like this this this and this need
to be done everybody go do it and they
just stand there looking at him yes team
arrow is fracturing but like all those
Diggle moments you know like Diggle kind
of calling the shots let you know that
he'll kind of be the go-to person
onca number three racial goals real plan
was to kill damian darhk-- i did wonder
if racial goal was gonna have some some
hidden reason for wanting oliver to
destroy Starling city and it's all
because of racial goals old nemesis
first off the set up for that rooftop
hotel scene that was just awesome
everybody is just lockstep they just
they cut to all the characters just each
taking someone down in an instant good
to go good to go bam good to go Nyssa
BAM good to go
the person that Oliver met is
Christopher hair doll he was on Gotham
he I mean he shows up everywhere I
looked on IMDB he was double billed as
damien darhk's assistant and damian
darhk-- himself he is a really strong
character actor so I could see him being
damian darhk-- in season four but it's
not confirmed I I don't know if that's
true if you want a Christopher hair doll
deep cut watch him on Stargate Atlantis
he played this really awesome Wraith
character kind of like a Malcolm Merlyn
character someone who's evil but works
with the heroes sometimes
but for those that are wondering yes
damian darhk-- is the season for villain
Marc Guggenheim confirmed that they were
setting the season for villain up they
were teeing him up in the finale and
that's who damian darhk-- is on to
number two speedy gets her costume if
there was any doubt about what her
comic-book name was gonna be oliver kind
of laid down the law I'm pretty sure I
already told everyone to call you speedy
so she is speedy but wearing Arsenal's
costume the costume department did have
to alter it just a little bit so that it
would fit her right Willa Holland is
like way smaller than Colton Haynes
would that be funny though if they were
the exact same size I haven't read any
articles about it yet but I'm wondering
if they always intended for Thea to
become the speedy character way back at
comic-con 2012 before season 1 premiered
they said that Katie Cassidy would
eventually become Black Canary so they
always planned for that to happen so so
you know sometimes I wonder how much
they pre plan and how much big character
stuff like that they change on the go
for those asking about Roy Colton Haynes
said that he would guest star on the
show again so we might see him during
season 4 but it'll only be as a guest
star like very briefly he is now Hero
for Hire just like wandering around in
the wilderness and finally my number one
WTF moment team arrow fractures everyone
goes their separate ways
so let's start at the top Oliver and
Felicity looked like they'd go on a
vacation this is kind of a longbow
hunters reference if you ever heard that
comic it just green arrow goes to
Seattle like he leaves Star City but
he's still green arrow so it's a little
bit different it's not a direct
reference in the context of the series
right now Oliver says that he is
retiring as the arrow that doesn't mean
that he's not gonna be a hero anymore
I mean he's not leaving the show but it
seems like for the first part of season
4 at least they're all gonna be in
separate parts of the world back in
Starling city you have the patrol team
you have Black Canary speedy and Diggle
I know Ray Palmer is still there but he
is actually going to the spin-off series
Brandon Roth is gonna be on that show so
you're not gonna see him on arrow
speaking of which teeny-tiny robots that
was basically him shrinking his suit
down so that means that he's probably
going to be shrinking on the spin-off
series so hopefully that answers
everyone's questions about that I know
everyone had been asking about it since
the minute it was announced that that
was the character that he was playing
era does a good job on delivering most
of the things that people asked for like
most of the
that you know that the fans want
sometimes it just takes a season to get
there
moving over to Merlin League of
Assassins now so at the end of the
episode Oliver gave him races ring the
way they explained it the bargain Oliver
made with Merlin is is that Merlin would
help him dismantle the league from the
inside if Oliver passed over leadership
of the league to him after it was all
over for that character I feel like
that's the best possible outcome because
he's mostly in Starling city because of
Thea's arc and she's kind of come full
circle so he's not really necessary for
her anymore you promised you'd make me
stronger and you did so there's really
no reason for him to stay in Starling
city anymore I have no idea how much
John Barrowman is gonna be featured in
season four but when he is featured it
will be part of a league storyline
damian darhk-- deep connections to the
League of Assassins so you can't do
damian darhk-- in hive without also
doing a little bit of league stuff I
also feel like we have the Suicide Squad
movie to thank for more League of
Assassins stuff the producers have said
that it's a little more difficult for
them to do Suicide Squad stories while
the Suicide Squad movie is happening
arrow needs another group of characters
to interact with you know just to keep
the story relevant to keep it from
getting too small so they lose the
Suicide Squad you have to replace it
with an organization that being the
League of Assassins so you can see
sometimes how like behind the scenes
corporate business stuff influences the
directions they take stories so here's
my big question for you guys you know
what was your favorite moment from the
episode and how long do you think it's
going to be before we see all of classic
teen arrow in a room together remember
what happened after the mid-season
finale you had like a couple episodes
where Oliver was on one side of the
world and team arrow was on their own
back in Starling city think of it as
looking like that Oliver was only gone
for a couple episodes they might stretch
that out a little bit more like in the
first arc of season four usually there's
like three mini arcs within a season I
think it'll help him pick up the pace of
the show too so if you feel like arrow
moves too slow if you like the pace of
the flash better I feel like arrow is
gonna get a little quicker here are some
really cool Easter eggs that I spotted
in the episode so first when Oliver was
fighting Rochelle Goyle on top of the
waterfall after he killed him he said
the same poem that Rachael Ghul said to
him when he killed Oliver in episode 9
and he even he even used the same bloody
blade Oliver
was using a blade that still had his own
blood on it I love that they went all
these weeks without cleaning that blade
off felicity inside the atom suit almost
made me fall out of my chair
the minute she and Ray Palmer started
having all those scenes together this
season I felt like she was kind of a
subordinate I was like why doesn't she
make herself some tech I mean she's
smarter than he is cut to BAM
Felicity wearing the suit just like
Pepper Potts for those of you that don't
read Iron Man comics Pepper Potts has
worn many different versions of the Iron
Man armor I'm not talking about Iron Man
3 just forget about that movie the armor
suits that she wears in the comics are
way cooler don't expect Felicity to
start doing stuff like that all the time
it was just like a fun finale moment she
doesn't know how to fly the suit the
reason why it works so well is because
you could remote pilot the atom suit
remember like when Oliver was using it
like a videogame that was actually fun
joke Ray Palmer's like I kind of hoped
that you played more video games as a
child so the really big news right now
they released a Supergirl trailer I
posted a video earlier if you haven't
seen it I'll add a link to it in the
description but there's also going to be
a legends of tomorrow trailer tomorrow
or at least there should be the CW is
having its up front so it'll announce
like win shows are coming back when
legends of tomorrow is gonna premiere
they'll show footage off it'll be a lot
of fun whatever they end up doing I'll
do a video so be sure to subscribe to
get that once we do learn what's going
on with the show I'll do another bonus
video for it like also doing legends of
tomorrow videos so in case you guys
haven't seen it they posted like 6
minutes of footage from the Supergirl
pilot you can click here to watch that
and you can click here for last night's
flash episode thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow
you